a first and a second for the Senate
tonight it's the first committee hearing
since fleeing Washington over the
coronavirus and it's the second time
around in the consideration for the
president's picked to be his
intelligence chief congressional
correspondent Chad program is on Capitol
Hill tonight I call this hearing to
order this hearing will be a little bit
different a hearing called to order for
the first time in two months DNI nominee
John Ratcliffe sat 40 feet from senators
in a cavernous hearing room a bottle of
Purell at his side senators usually
squeezed onto the dais for a hearing but
Intelligence Committee Chairman Richard
Burr limited how many senators could sit
in the hearing room at once senators had
to stay in their offices until it was
their turn to ask Ratcliffe questions
this is a do-over for Ratcliffe to be
the nation's top spy president Trump
tapped the congressman to succeed
resigning DNI dan coates last summer but
Ratcliffe pulled out after bipartisan
questions arose about his qualifications
and you start out day one down 47 to
nothing because every Democrat is
against you my concern was there's not a
lot of margin for error there and
president Trump tweeted that he told
Ratcliffe quote how miserable it would
be for him and his family to deal with
these people the president never
nominated somebody else and the fall
Ratcliffe emerged as one of mr. Trump's
most ardent defenders during impeachment
hearings President Trump gave Ratcliffe
a mulligan Democrats wondered what
changed he is a deeply partisan
cheerleader for the president a yes man
in every sense of the phrase someone who
doesn't speak truth to power to the
President of the United States
Ratcliffe assured senators he wouldn't
tilt intelligence to align with the
president he pledged independence even
as mr. Trump has suggested the
intelligence community tried to
undermine him whether you're talking
about the president whether you're
talking about Nancy Pelosi Mitch
McConnell anyone's views on what they
want the intelligence to be will never
impact the intelligence that I deliver
never Ratcliffe testified that he didn't
think that the intelligence community
had run amuck he also sidestepped a
question about intelligence agencies and
the deep state his
confirmation vote should come before the
full Senate later this month
Bret Chad thank you